uh we are very excited about our next
guest best-selling author brene brown
she is taking an in-depth look at human
emotions in a new docu-series it's
called brene brown atlas of the heart
same as the book
and it's out today there's serious draws
on research from her latest book also
called atlas of the heart it's a
five-episode series and she explores
30 emotions and experiences that she
says we all have take a look
the biggest mistake we make about who we
are
is believing that we are thinking beings
that we are cognitive
driven
people
who on occasion
stumble into emotion
move it out of our way flick it aside
and get back to our thinking selves this
is not true
we are above all else emotional beings
who on occasion think
i like that and that is a hundred
percent true brene brown joins us now to
talk about the series this is a first on
cbs mornings we like when we can say
that uh brene good morning to you thank
you for being here yeah all right we're
very excited we're very excited and i'm
also very curious uh how you took your
list of i think 87 emotions we all need
to be able to name and understand and
talk about that's from the book and then
got it down to 30 and put it into a
five-part tv series what was that like
um what whittling the emotions down was
painful um you know you're like oh no
you have to have this one you have to
have this one but i think we we ended up
with the ones that we wrestle with every
day the emotions that we really need to
understand that are core to the human
experience and so we whittle down the 87
to 30. um and the experience was
incredible you know i i'm i don't have a
lot of experience any experience on
television and so i was nervous and
scared but i just had this incredible
production team and an amazing crew and
they just kind of said you play football
which is a metaphor i understand you
play football and we'll take care of the
rest so you just pretend like you're in
the classroom which is a comfortable
place for me um and we'll take it from
there so i was really lucky to be
surrounded by very gifted people
yeah you were very very comfortable on
stage i'm so glad the book was so great
brene we had you here for the book i'm
so glad that you're now bringing it to
on screen so people can hear you while
you're talking because as you said
you're a great teacher but i love in the
piece you said you surveyed 7 000 people
10 years ago and three emotions kept
coming up happy sad pissed off that's
something that we can all relate to you
said we need to expand our languaging
yeah i mean just imagine
just imagine
if all we have are these three buckets
what happens when we experience awe
wonder resentment joy anguish and we
have to shove them into buckets where
they don't fit and the reason why this
is so problematic
is that language doesn't just convey
emotion or communicate emotion it shapes
neurologically what we're feeling
so when we mislabel emotion we are
actually changing our experience and so
we it's important to get the language
right man language is so powerful
it is but and emotion is so powerful and
i think we need to kind of drive into an
issue that i think we have as a country
when it comes to emotion we raise kids
to think that emotion is something you
need to put aside to get whatever your
job is done to get your schoolwork done
um and that is deeply problematic
particularly for little boys so what
what do you say to that kind of negative
idea that we have from the get-go about
recognizing emotions let alone naming
them and talking about them
yeah i think it just it it comes back to
that piece that y'all that clipped you
showed
we are inherently emotional beings when
we make decisions when we are in fear
when we experience joy when we're
excited about the possibility of
learning
that's emotion and let me tell you when
emotion is driving
behavior and thinking are not like
riding in the front seat they're hot
tied in the trunk
like when emotion is thriving
it and and when we're not aware of it
we lose our power to choose that's why
when it comes to emotion language is a
portal
into universes of new choices and second
chances if i can say
god why did i show up like that in that
meeting
why was i so crappy with that person you
know and then understand what's driving
our behavior and our thinking
so so one of the things that you do in
the show is you act out these scenarios
with audience members um and at one
point you did it to illustrate the
differences between sympathy empathy and
compassion which i think a lot of people
sometimes struggle to define how would
you explain that to our audience
yeah so we did these role plays and it
was so fun
one of the greatest i think gifts of
this research is this concept of near
enemy
a near enemy is masquerades is the
quality that we're seeking but actually
undermines it so the near enemy of
empathy is sympathy so in these role
plays like so if if gayle calls me and
says hey bernie i just had this really
hard day and this happened and i was
really stressed out and my response is
oh bless your heart you poor thing
yes
like i just heard gail
um
does that feel good no that
you know empathy drives connection
sympathy drives disconnection sympathy
is hey i feel sorry for you from over
here where that kind of stuff doesn't
happen
you know and so
man that's not true it is it is you said
that anguish is the most difficult
emotion what's the best emotion you call
yourself sister superior because you're
the oldest of four siblings just leave
us on what's the best emotion then we'll
let you go
siblings call me that not me first of
all i think
aw and wonder
make us feel small compared to the
universe but make us feel deeply
connected to each other
renee brown language is a portal your
series is a portal as well thank you
very much
great to see you all five episodes of
brene brown atlas of the heart are
available now to stream on hbo max